You are now ready to connect the graph
Laplacian, its eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and graph partitioning.
But first some handy facts.
I'll just state these without proof.
If you need that,
please see the paper by Pothen et al,
posted in the instructors notes.
The first key fact is that
the Laplacian is symmetric.
This follows from its definition.
An important consequence of
this fact is the second fact.
The eigen values of the Laplacian
will be real-valued and non-negative.
I say real-valued as
opposed to complex-valued.
The Laplacian's eigen vectors
will also be real-valued.
And we can define them to be orthogonal.
If you've forgotten what
an eigenvalue and eigonvector are,
here's a quick reminder.
Eigenvalues and eigenvectors are paired.
Let's let land to i and
Q sub i be an eigenvalue and
an eigenvector respectively of L of G.
And the following holds,
multiply L of G by it's eigenvector
gives you a scaled version
of the eigenvector.
The scaling factor is the eigenvalue.
You can also write this differently in
matrix form, L(G) Q = Q times lambda.
Q and lambda are matrices.
In particular, the columns of Q
are the eigenvectors of L(G).
Lamb dot is a diagonal matrix where all
the eigen values sit on the diagonal.
What about this orthogonal bit?
Orthogonality tells us that
the dot product between any
pair of eigen vectors will be
zero if they're different.
Or one if they're the same.
In more compact matrix notation,
Q transposed times Q is
the identity matrix.
Now what about this
non-negative eigen values bit?
That tells us that all the eigen
values are at least zero.
Now a common convention is to assume
that we can sort the eigen values So
let's do that too.
We'll let the eigenvalues
with the smaller indices,
be the smaller eigenvalues.
So in this case,
lambda0 is the smallest eigenvalue, and
lambda1 is the second smallest.
Now here's a third fact which
I find especially interesting.
It says that the graph G has
K connected components if and
only if the K smallest
values are identically zero.
This is a fact due to Fiedler.
And when I first learned this fact,
I was like, wow..
I mean omg wow, like seriously,
as in srsly seriously.
It's a cool fact because it says,
the graph laplacian spectrum,
meaning it's eigen values,
tells us something about the underlying
connectivity of the graph.
Here's one more important fact.
Let's say you have a graph that's
been partitioned into two pieces,
one piece is the plus piece, and
the other piece is the minus piece.
Let's let v plus be the set of
vertices in the plus piece and
v minus the set of vertices in the minus
piece, now this is all graph language.
What about the linear algebra side?
Let’s define a vector x with
respect to this partition.
Each entry of x will correspond
to a particular vertex.
We’ll assign that entry a positive
one if the vertex lies in V plus and
a minus one if the vertex is in V minus.
Now, suppose you want to count
the number of edges that are being
cut in the graph.
This leads us to our fourth fact.
The number of cut edges is this product.
One-fourth x transpose L times x.
This fact is also very nice.
It says that if you want
to minimize edge cuts,
you should try minimizing this product.
Okay, so
let's quickly summarize the four facts.
Take a moment to digest them.
Once you've done so, you're ready for
the spectral partitioning algorithm.